ja dieser begriff ist ein sehr komplexer
griff das deutsche wort geist hat ganz
verschiedene bedeutungen
es kann ein mensch geistreich genannt
werden es gibt etwas wie den geist des
20 jahrhunderts den geist der stadt
steckt der stadt münchen zum beispiel
also der begriff das wort geist ist sehr
viel deutet
der geist begriff eignet sich besonders
dazu subjektivität also die mentalen
phänomene des einzelnen individuen ist
und allgemeinere phänomenen die die
gesellschaft betreffen die geschichte
betreffen miteinander zu verbinden
und wir finden bei kant diesen begriff
schon angedacht kant behandelt diesen
begriff aber nicht in seinen drei
kritiken er hat keine kritik des geistes
geschrieben wir eine kritik des
verstandes der vernunft der urteilskraft
verfasst hat aber dennoch spielt der
begriff des keils da kann eine wichtige
rolle
kant kommt auf den begriff zu sprechen
im kontext der ästhetik die frage was
das genie auszeichnet und da ist ein
ganz wichtiger bestandteil das kann sagt
der geist ist das belebende prinzip des
gemüts also geist ist nicht irgendwie
eine disco getanzt eine schwebende
substanz die über dem leben existiert
sein geistigkeit es immer verwoben mit
dem leben könnte sagen eine art von
synthese von vernunft und leben das ist
glaube ich das wichtigste was den geist
auszeichnet und es gibt ein neues buch
dem titel die aktualität des geistes und
darin finden sich verschiedene beiträge
die im geist begriff bei ganz wichtigen
philosophen behandeln beginnend mit kant
fichte hegel schelling aber auch neuere
philosophen wie kassierer und atom